so my eight-year-old son did something
special this last week that i was
inspired to share with you i think gonna
take a lot away from what he did here so
he's not feeling well dylan he's sick
runny nose
throat not feeling good energy's down
doesn't go to school one day we take him
to the doctor we thought he had coveted
he test negative but he's not feeling
good sore throat everything is just down
and every day in the family the the kids
are required to read 20 pages every day
the oldest is required to read 40 but
dylan's still at 20. he'll be going to
40 here soon and make 52 shots so they
go outside to make the shots and i'm
watching him to see if he's going to do
it or not my older son shoots the 52
shots quickly because his energy is high
and at 35 shots that he's made dylan
just looks at me and he's just not
looking good
and he's like runny nose all this stuff
is like daddy i just don't feel good i
just don't feel good to the point where
his throat is hurting him so bad he
starts crying so as a dad i look at him
i'm like hey dylan listen don't worry
about it don't push her it's totally
fine you're not feeling good let's go
inside let's take a break he says no i'm
not going to take a break i said dylan
go inside take a break i'm telling him
to go inside and take a break he says i
have to make my 52 shots right so watch
i said dylan just take a break
everyone's watching i'm not going to go
i'm not going inside after big by 52
shots and he cries tears coming down he
makes every single shot till 52.
he walks away when i go when he'll take
him inside and i pat him in the back i
said i'm so proud of you and i said i
had to whisper something to him
i told him i said you know this is a
very proud moment with your daddy he
says why is that i said because i have
high expectations of you i said well you
raised dad's expectations today and you
took it to your own standards and
expectation you said this is your
standards and expectation but i want to
go here i want to learn how to play hurt
and he did that on his own i walked away
i got emotional i told the story to
uh uh 50 of our guys that we had an
emergency meeting with in dallas and i
told him this i couldn't even hold
myself i got so emotional let me tell
you why i got so emotional about it
because
for me i can't tell you
how much people impress me when they
choose to go above and beyond what i
think is high standard i'm inspired by
people like that
it's i think the one of the reasons why
i'm inspired by this is because
that was one of the things i had if you
met the 18 19 20 year old kid or 21 year
old guy working at bally's and you work
with me you would have said this guy had
no clue what the hell he was doing but
if we asked him to do this he would
always wanted to do this if the trainer
tells you go 12 times you go 15 times if
you know your your coach tells you you
know i want you to run a mile you run a
mile and a quarter if the coach tells
you i want you to make 100 shots you do
120. it's always not letting people's
standards be your standards you always
say you don't dictate my standards i
dictate my standards and my standards
are higher than anybody else is going to
expect of me the moment you do that what
you're telling the world is i can stand
on my own two feet
and i'm going to do something special
with my life i don't need the world to
set the standards of my life i'm going
to do it you're somebody that's very
rare to find any company any
organization anybody any uh a wife
husband kids peers friends
organizations nonprofits charities
political organizations anybody would be
more than happy to have somebody like
you because people like that are so rare
to find my deal as a parent is to see my
kids want to go above and beyond what i
expect them that made me so proud to see
that taking place so going back to you
today
when people tell you what to do are you
the one that says oh my gosh this is too
much there's too much pressure and you
go below what people think you're
capable of doing are you the one that
always just meets the standard of what
people are capable people think you're
capable of doing are you the person that
says
forget about what you think i'm capable
of doing you you want me to do this i
think i can do this i think the product
is good but i want to make it great
because it's my signature on this
product
that level of pride of going above and
beyond is so valuable there is no the
average salary for a person that goes
above and beyond there is no value for
that that's priceless that's one of
those things that the market values
immensely that i value immensely and
it's something that all of us can take
inventory of so dylan
you watch this video one day when you're
28 years old uh today when this happened
was a day before your birthday it was
two days before your birthday we just
celebrated your eighth birthday
september 24th does your birthday
if you ever see this i'm so proud of you
buddy when you did this at seven years
old it was three days before you're
turning eight years old your daddy's
very proud i hope you continue
uh that level of standard you had with
yourself when you were seven years old i
hope you're doing it at 20 30 40 years
old and everybody else hopefully we
learn something from dylan here today so
if you like what dylan did give him a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
and i got another video for you i did on
mental toughness if you've never seen
this whole video with this 21 minutes
all i talk about is how to become more
mentally tough if you've never watched
it click over here to watch it with that
being said have a great week everybody
take care bye
[Music]